the World Health Organization you keep
hearing about Ted Rose O'Donnell and
you're seeing a lot of friendliness with
him in China and he's sat down with Xi
Jinping you've seen this before it's now
I'm not the first person that's bringing
this up how much a World Health
Organization is being controlled by the
influence of China on what to report
what not to report slow roll you know
the dates at first it's not that big of
a big deal you know it's okay and then
US shuts it down and oh my gosh u.s. is
racist and they don't care about Chinese
people how could you do something like
this and then they said no it's a
serious pandemic the timing was very
often the world relies on this World
Health Organization our World Health
Organization Ted Rose and China and met
together
so they'd certainly appear to be that
way Patrick
um you got to look at what the w-h-o did
in this circumstance and it is there's
no adjectives in the English language
which describes how bad Ted rose and the
w-h-o were so for instance I talked
about that January 14th tweet where the
WH O's propagated help China propagate
the notion that there are no human to
human transmission of coronavirus where
a wh oh I'm sure knew that there were
how could they not know about it I mean
there are World Health Organization
they've got doctors also on January 10th
WH o came out with the statement to
support China's goal of not having
countries imposed travel restrictions on
arrivals from China so you put those two
things together and it shows that the
w-h-o was very much supporting Beijing's
initiatives and Beijing's initiatives
had to be malicious also you know Ted
Rose did a number of other things so for
instance in January he delayed for as
long as possible
WH OS formal designation of the corona
virus as a public health emergency of
international concern
also he delayed for as long as possible
the WH OS designation of Cora
virus as a pandemic which eventually
occurred I think on March 11th we saw
red rose in Beijing at the end of
January talk about how other countries
should emulate China's system and talked
about the quote unquote superiority of
China's system which is thinly veiled
the veiled attacked on democracy and
then of course w-h-o has very much been
supporting the notion that china's
statistics are accurate
none of those route would be I think
actions of the organization that really
was dedicated to stopping the virus from
infecting people so you put that
together the one thing you can say is
that if you took the Communist Party of
China and the World Health Organization
together they're responsible for this
taking this which should have just been
a local outbreak in Wuhan or maybe even
who Bay Province and making it first of
all a nationwide epidemic in China plus
also a global pandemic
none of those last two things would have
occurred had not these two organizations
Communist Party and w-h-o acted together
so you can you can argue about who's
more responsible and I think of course
it's the Communist Party but the point
is whu-oh helped spread this coronavirus
around the world and so that its actions
on balance have been maligned and that
leads us to a number of conclusions
about what we do you talked about the
funding of w-h-o that's right the u.s.
by far is the largest funder we put 440
million dollars in the w-h-o last year
you add Bill Gates that's a lot of other
money we shouldn't be doing that why why
would what's them everything to me is
about motive right everything is motive
we get married why do you get married
there's a motive why do you ask a girl
out well there's a motive why don't you
see say yes motive why do you buy a real
estate motive why do you buy a car
motive why do you wear clothes motive
what why do we do anything there's a
behind it doesn't mean all the motive is
negative it just means there's motive
behind it some days I'm positive okay
but what is the motive between World
Health Organization protecting China
that's what I'm curious about you know I
don't know I don't know Ted Rousseau I'm
not in his head so I can't tell you what
his motive is but you know you can say
that China lobbied very hard for his
election as director general of w-h-o he
has very leftist tendencies maybe
there's an answer in there you know it's
a question I understand why you're
looking at motive but you know motive is
one thing that you know is really hard
to ascertain with certainty because as I
said I don't know in fact what C Jinping
was thinking I don't know in fact what
Ross is thinking but I don't really need
to know all I can see is what they did
and that's really where we can see the
crimes of that they've committed so I I
don't know motive but as I said I don't
care
yeah only reason I ask is because if
somebody is working closely with Ted
Rose and let's just say they're in a
meeting and they're 40 50 of them and
they're on the inside and they know the
decisions that were made there's no way
in the world Ted the Rose is the only
one that's making a decision I I trust
there's another 20 30 40 people that are
in the know of why the decisions were
made somebody in that group has to be
furious because someone in their life
they lost somebody or it affected
somebody or they were affected because
their elderly parents were relying on a
retirement plan now they have to work
harder or one of their relatives lost a
bit someone has to be furious on the
inside with Ted Rose to be able to come
out of salus and I don't think you're
doing a good job just like this 37 year
old doctor out of a you know Wuhan who
came out it was a whistle blower to
China and said this is not we're not
doing the right thing he ended up
passing away he disappeared I don't
recall that but I think the only reason
I'm asking motive is because I do
believe everybody at some level has a
certain level of decency to say I just
don't think we're doing the right thing
now we got to do
something about this well you know
especially this magnitude this is not a
small thinker this is a very big thing
here someone has to come out of some
what really happened well you know Bruce
Alwine al Ward who is you know generally
been described as the number two and
w-h-o his formal title is senior advisor
to the director-general a couple days
ago he came out with an interview where
he said you know it was very important
for us at an early stage of the outbreak
to be able to study this so we needed
China's cooperation which is really what
his message was so I suppose you could
say that for some people to w-h-o they
were saying well we got to be nice to
China to butter them up so they'll allow
us to go to study it but you know as we
just talked about WH oh they stiffed
armed w-h-o in Wuhan so whatever the
motive was and that's really pretty
you just said WH o sniff harm WH oh no
no no try and stick darn W a job okay
preventing them from an adequate
opportunity to study the for the virus I
suppose you know one could say that
maybe that was what they were thinking
but you know it's very very difficult to
discern motive what we have to do is is
look at what they did and what they
should have known at the time that they
committed certain acts and that needs to
very dark conclusions about not only
China but about the w-h-o one of the
most annoying things that my dad did to
me is hold me accountable I hated it I
couldn't stand it when I was in the army
I couldn't stand being held accountable
to formation and you got to get in and
four o'clock and you got Iran and you
got a report accountability is very
annoying accountability also builds
leaders and accountability builds trust
one of the thing that seems very common
here that's missing is accountability it
concerns me when I even brought it up to
you earlier I said how should trying to
be held accountable at the you know
world tribunal and you're like well it's
not really we have to figure out a way
to get past this and you said we need to
maybe go back to wouldn't you know
Nuremberg and Japan and you
Germany all that stuff but if there is
no accountability why wouldn't I do it
again if there's no consequences why
wouldn't I do it's like it's a slap and
a hand it's okay okay I know problem
you're okay if I do this again I'm gonna
do it again and again and again because
you need me so where does accountability
come into play here yeah well you know
that's absolutely right and that's why I
said we need to impose some cost because
if we don't do that they'll do this
again you know I suppose the one thing
that will happen and this is something
that is within our power to do is that
countries are going to start isolating
China for four decades for five decades
countries have tried to integrate China
into the international system they
thought it was a positive good and
because of that they overlooked a lot of
irresponsible and dangerous conduct on
the part of Beijing because they wanted
to encourage to entice China so that it
would mesh itself in the you know rules
norms conventions treaties but you know
it hasn't worked and what we're seeing
is I think people starting to understand
that china is not reformable and if
China is not reformable that leads to
the conclusion that we need to get China
out of the UN out of the World Trade
Organization out of the World Health
Organization and just start to isolate
it and I know people don't want to do
that but you got to remember you know we
always think you know China should be
moving on the right path if you look at
what China did in the SARS epidemic of
2000 to 2003 it was really awful but as
awful as it was its behavior in the
corona virus epidemic of 2019 - you know
2020 is it's been much much worse than
it was and so we've got to understand
that our idea of engaging China just has
not worked and we've got to try
something else and I'm not saying I
can't hold my hand over my heart and
saying that isolating china will be any
better I think it will and that's a long
conversation in and of itself but we
have to say that what we have been doing
has not worked it's encouraged China to
be more religious
more provocative more hostile more
dangerous so we've got to do something
else
[Music]